let's say it cost me 100 bucks to a Car
customer and let's say it cost me 100
bucks to fulfillment I have to make $600
in cash in the first 30 days from that
Prospect if I can do that I cover their
cost of fulfillment and their cost of
acquisition and the cost of acquiring
and fulfilling the next customer off of
that initial and then at that point we
no longer have a marketing budget we can
spend as much money as we damn well
please in the acquisition and then
operations becomes the bottleneck of
scale and so that is why each of the
companies has scaled at such a rapid
rate is because I don't need anyone's
money to do it and why we've owned every
one of the companies outright without
taking on outside capital